[Aplausos]
[Música]
soy abogado
ustedes supongo pensaban que yo iba a
ser algo de humorismo
pero voy a hablar de medicina
[Música]
voy a hablar de la risa
y de la fábrica de la risa es el humor
lo cómico
y lo voy a ayudar le voy a dar una
muestra bueno les decía lo de la risa
por lo siguiente básicamente
ella constituye uno de los medicamentos
fundamentales para las personas sin
saberlo cuando nosotros reímos
el movimiento de 35 músculos algo por el
estilo
nos están transmitiendo al organismo una
serie de hormonas las activan como son
las dopamina
hay muchas de ellas las cuales casi
equivalen a la morfina por ello es que
casi todos los gobiernos suelen golpear
la risa el chiste porque ellos
consideran que están haciendo algo malo
y es volver feliz a las personas
la risa es una velas
mejores medicinas que existen nos ayuda
en el corazón el sistema directivo el
cerebro se beneficia como ninguno porque
nos aleja del estrés la primera causa de
muerte del mundo aunque parezca que es
el corazón u otra enfermedad
ahora claro cuando se habla de la risa
hay que irse a buscar obligatoriamente
usted llega a una farmacia y dice deme
una cajita de risa no se la vende por
desgracia ese medicamento solo surge de
una fábrica particular que se llama el
humor
los humoristas son los médicos que
colaboran y diría yo en la medida en que
me toca he colaborado a la felicidad de
muchas personas eso me hace sentir a mí
todavía mucho más feliz que los mismos
que habrán disfrutado del medicamento
en este sentido le puedo decir que el
humorismo y la comicidad en general
es un arte complejo un arte complejo
porque
supone tres cosas fundamentales para
lograrlo adecuadamente en primer lugar
está sin la menor duda una condición
innata en las personas que lo tienen esa
capacidad se nace con el parte de
evidencia venezolanas precisamente
podría decir que es esa condición de un
ser amable y dado a enseñar cosas
cómicas
dado a alegrar al ambiente esa fue la
gran venezuela nuestra y todavía quedan
muchas raíces en las cuales nosotros
estamos
por el otro lado existe una capacidad
sin duda que no todo el mundo tampoco
tiene y es la de desmontar una realidad
que se nos ha enfrentado y que tiene
adentro falsedades es decir el test
monta y destruye todo lo que está
sobrando sobre la realidad que puede ser
cruel o puede ser abiertamente solo
sorprendente y ya con eso es suficiente
el rompe
el humorista rompe un equilibrio una
apariencia un rigor
y al romperlo produce o la risa o la
sonrisa pero como veremos
se parecen mucho pero solamente 97
músculo del rostro sin embargo en el
cerebro trabaja más cuando uno sonríe es
porque aquello es
algo que requería inteligencia un
poquito mayor
la risa es colectiva e incluso en
algunos animales para ese este ha sido
probado las ratas ríen los perros cuando
están jugando entre sí si hay una cierta
cosa animal que no requiere mayores
condiciones y la última condición básica
pues en esta fábrica
es una capacidad de construir después
que destruirte después que de
desmitificas te una falsa edad
tienes que hacerlo presentarlo de alguna
manera en que todo el mundo pueda
apreciar lo que tú buscas lo que produce
la risa
de allí que nosotros nos encontremos que
en humor del humorismo como tal presenta
varias formas porque todo podría ser
humorístico pero no es así hay distintas
disciplinas técnicas diferentes yo les
diría que una velas para comenzar con la
más sencilla del mundo que es el chiste
es una forma de hacer humor el chiste es
el más fácil
el máximo nos requiere condiciones
especiales casi todas ustedes han
inventado o transmitido un chiste de
mañana me contaron uno que media me
recordó para referirlo en una habitación
en la noche la mujer le dice al marido
carlos carlos despiértate me estás
insultando dormido
y el marido le responde que entendió que
yo estoy dormido
a hacer chistes
y como le dije es fácil tengo una
anécdota muy particular que me demuestra
ese poder tan increíble de ser feliz de
esta forma tan sencilla del humor lo
recuerdo porque fue en la ciudad de
paraná hace muchísimos años
nos encontramos un grupo de venezolanos
que estábamos en distintas actividades
en europa
un gran cantante de los grandes bajos
venezolano de los mejores cantantes que
esté saliendo él
el indio el que trabajaba en la ópera de
viena
[Música]
nos reunió una tarde y nos pusimos a las
5 de la tarde a tomarnos una cerveza y
hasta las 12 de la noche
siendo estuvo contándonos chistes y
todos muertos de la risa eso no era no
era concebible después todavía después
de 50 o 60 años de esta época yo no lo
puedo creer que no hayamos reído tanto
con un hombre
y por lo los que vale la pena recordar y
yo lo diría siempre que como los pudiera
rememorar en tanto si todos manteniendo
esa línea de humor sin la menor duda que
era por su condición de cantante de
ópera que se supone pues el bombín a la
memoria de ellos es superior a las
nuestras normales por eso pudo hacer la
otra forma
[Música]
pero caricatura
le presentó una de la caricatura más
significativa que ha visto en los
últimos tiempos
fíjense la simplicidad de esa caricatura
no requiere dibujante
no quiere no hace falta ni el genio de
kino ni de zapata para deformar una o
mostrarnos una sorpresa
esta es otra de las formas
aunque debo hacer hincapié que fuera de
las condiciones que les he señalado para
poder hacer humor el de la caricatura
requiere una condición particular qué es
estética capacidad de dibujo y de ahí
que haya grandes pintores que son
caricaturistas hay caricaturistas que
siguen casi todos ellos sin excepción
siendo humoristas gráficos pero ellos
también ejercitan el dibujo y la pintura
y he visto obras maravillosas de muchos
de ellos entre ellos
recuerdo que había un caricaturista
maravilloso argentino que hacía cuadros
que eran superiores el caso igual que el
de pedro león zapata aquellas
caricaturas que tanta la tanto
entusiasmo producían
después de ella yo les voy a dar algo
que es importante la otra de las formas
que ya entra en el mundo pseudo litis
literario pero por ahí van porque ya la
palabra escrita es la parodia otra de
las formas creadoras del humor
y les voy a leer a ustedes los podrán
leer
un día como pasado mañana una parodia
del tal día como hoy
la colgate palmolive inventa la voz
no
[Música]
dicte el decreto que prohíbe
terminantemente la tela de poliéster
porque son cancerígeno
mahoma
[Música]
prohibió el aumento de los precios
esto es muy importante porque la gente
no cree que eso ocurrió
[Música]
se fue la primera tragedia médica de la
historia
está buenísimo en venezuela
estamos acostumbrados
este caso
[Música]
su meta fiscal
salió esta es la eterna corrupción en
venezuela
curiosamente también hay una al este es
una otra variación esas son tomadas de
algún libro mío que no lo recuerdo pero
bon jovi ya el terror de cuando uno va
apurado
el relleno lo espere
en cambio las veces pero obvia es lo
mismo pero repite más de tres veces
y la patria pánico de a robar no hasta
la cabeza a sentir que lo piense nos
salen por el otro lado
eeuu todos ustedes sin excepción
la olla
terrible es el asombro yo
y estas las sufren casi todos ustedes
todos tenemos una fobia o no
la madre está hacia típica de venezuela
a móvil de moda
los que había mucho entrega en el
cerebro vivo asustado
julio obvio todos sabemos quiénes somos
esto se refiere ya a la otra forma que
existe de hacer un modismo que es la
novela esto ella propiamente literatura
aquí hay una mezcla
volvamos tenemos el que desmitifica una
realidad tiene esa capacidad de
descubrir todos los detallitos pero
tiene que esforzarse en la forma mucho
más que nosotros porque la novela es
literatura desgraciadamente para que
tenga un valor de cierto nivel pues hay
que saber escribir un poco cosa que le
puedo decir con mucha franqueza yo no
era nunca novelista yo era un humorista
común y corriente perdone este ese
humorista no sabía escribir y terminé
escribiendo tres novelas muchas de ellas
mejor dicho todas han sido bclm en el
sentido de muchas ediciones en unas el
terrorista le hicieron una para cine en
francia pero era tan costosa que no se
pudo hacer porque había que recorrer
todo el mundo esa novela tiene una
historia muy particular en mi caso
porque yo tuve un cargo internacional
que fue realmente de gracias al primer
premio pero el más grande premio que yo
me haya podido imaginar que se podía
ganar a alguien
no un buen dinero sino un cargo
internacional cuando era joven en la
federación mundial de juventudes la cual
me llevó en tres años y medio que lo
desempeñe a recorrer el planeta por lo
menos en 80 países en esa época la
locura porque puede conocer países gente
éxito y yo de ese viaje de esa gran
experiencia pasados los años reconstruir
porque anotaba cada uno de los sitios y
las cosas interesantes que veía lo
transformé en una novela en donde era
todo lo contrario de lo que yo hacía yo
hacía conferencias juveniles preparando
conferencias para
distintas cosas relacionadas a la
juventud y yo lo volví un terrorista
porque se puso de moda el primer
terrorismo antes de que empezaran éstos
un nuevo dell de ahí este grupo y era el
italiano que se llamaba el ejército rojo
que puso a sacudir a italia estaban los
animales y también tenían unas fuerzas
terroristas peligrosísimas y es el libro
pues fue un gran best seller también en
el sentido de que se sacaron ya estas
dos ediciones en muy buenas cantidades
se vendieron ya no existe esa
posibilidad porque me han hecho de la ya
no se puede editar
fuera de esto existe también la poesía
humorística de una pequeña poesía mía
de uno de los libros y esa es la cara de
la mujer
qué me importa que digan que no te
importó si no te importó mucho digan lo
que digan por eso sólo digo que solo
importa que te diga lo mucho que me
importa no importa lo que digas este es
el tipo de cosa que es una deformación
cosa que en mi caso es un juego muy
aventurero porque yo no soy un poeta esa
es otra de las condiciones que requiere
así como el caricaturista requiere
condiciones estéticas de dibujo muy
buenas
el novelista tiene que meterse en ese
mundo largo igual que el hombre que
escribe cuentos de humor en el caso de
la poesía es mucho más difícil nosotros
tenemos la suerte en venezuela de haber
tenido dos grandes poetas entre ellos
andrés eloy blanco que hizo maravillas
en poesía humorística estuvo el más
grande de todos ha sido aquiles nazoa
sin duda
un poeta magistral y además humorista de
primera
luego de la poesía tenemos a la ironía
la más difícil de todas la forma este es
un profesor en filosofía juan nuño en
paz descanse un español maravilloso de
una de un nivel filosófico una cultura
filosófica asombrosa
lo que hice mucho por eso es algo lo
saco ahora adelante y él
uno de los escritores escribía mucho en
el papel literario 'el nacional' en
donde lo que transmitía era tan profundo
donde destruía a un adversario
generalmente político
nadie se daba cuenta porque estaba tan
libre el que solamente la gente
demasiado inteligente captaba la ironía
que estaba escrita en aquellos textos
esa es otra de la forma y es muy
corriente y se considera la forma
sublime la más alta de las formas del
humor porque la más difícil porque ya
supone el dominio de la letra el secreto
de cómo puedo yo
sin que se ofendan ofenderlo
y eso es un arte muy difícil
luego tenemos
el teatro ese no es propiamente imagen
para él el teatro estamos hablando eso
nace estoy hablando en humor en la vieja
y antigua grecia aristófanes de los
grandes dramaturgos
y dramáticos comediantes de los con los
cuales comienza el teatro griego a
fortalecerse bien en toda la historia de
la humanidad hasta que de pronto llega
algo que se llama el cine y la
televisión entonces también el gran
humor en estos nuevos medios y siguiente
en relación a lo que hemos hablado de
esas maneras del pasado
estamos encontrándonos en este instante
con una distinta que completa supone
muchas personas supone libretistas de
primera y actores el grupo es
fundamental si no lo logras finalmente
tenemos la fotografía
esto parece tétrico pero saben que es
basura como están rompiendo las bolsas
nosotros en la casa decidimos meter la
basura en esos paquetes que parece un
muerto y para no enredarse con el
asesinato no los toca el paquete
bueno
debo decirles que la intención mía era
orientarles de cómo hacer humor cosa que
veo que va a ser difícil el tiempo
avanzado de una manera
terriblemente rápida y me queda muy poco
tiempo y yo les voy a recomendar más
bien que compren mis libros o que simple
y llanamente no se pongan inventando
algo que no es tan fácil muchas gracias
[Música]